hey this is Sarah with registered nurse
Orion comm and today I want to show you
how to put a tourniquet on a patient
whenever you draw blood or start an IV
you'll have to put a tourniquet on and I
just want to give you a quick video on
how to do that with quick-release it
takes a little practice so after you
watch this video I would try to practice
on someone in your family or friend so
you can get the hang of it so here we go
first what you're going to do is you're
going to explain to the patient where
you're going to do and you're going to
take your left hand in your right hand
and you're going to stretch the
tourniquet as far as you can but being
comfortable to the patient to the back
of the arm and you're going to cross it
like a shoestring okay have it cross and
then you're going to take your dominant
hand and you're going to sort of do a
little loop underneath this area and
then just leave it like so okay and then
you do your start your IV draw your
blood and then when you're done do the
quick release and you're just going to
pull it like so and it comes off and now
I'm going to show you how to do it
really fast because that was sort of
slow motion so this is what it looks
like whenever you do it naturally all
done
so doing that it takes a little practice
so like I said just watch this video
over and over and practice and you'll
get it down in no time if you want to
watch some more videos on some nursing
skills be sure to check out my youtube
channel and subscribe to it and also be
sure to visit my website registered
nurse or en comm it's great for anyone
who's going to nursing school or if
you're a nurse and check out the forum
and thank you so much for watching